welcome back chamath paliapitia is a
billionaire out in california in silicon
valley he's a huge donor to the
democratic party he's also the part
owner of the nba team the golden state
warrior so in a recent podcast he went
out and told the truth
and he said what he personally thinks
about china's human rights abuses it's
genocide it's murder
of the ethnic minority the uyghurs watch
this
yeah nobody cares about what's happening
to the weakers okay you you bring it up
because you really care and i think what
do you mean you care the rest of us
don't care i'm just telling you very
hard you're saying you virtually don't
care i'm telling you a very hard ugly
truth okay of all the things that i care
about yes it is below my line
repulsive human being obviously you got
to kind of admire his honesty
can't be honest we're glad he was so the
golden state warriors issued a statement
that read this way mr polyapia does not
speak on behalf of our franchise and of
course the billionaire himself issued a
statement saying well i my family came
from a country with mean people and by
the way the united states is human
rights abuses too
even more repulsive than you would ever
imagine of course the golden state
warriors didn't even mention the uyghurs
in their statement you wouldn't want to
upset china say the word taiwan we dare
you
enos cantor freedom knows a lot about
how this all works he plays for the
boston celtics he recently became an
american citizen he's very proud of that
the second time he's joined us and we're
glad he's here mr freedom thank you very
much for coming on tonight so to hear
someone say it oh i like your shirt to
see if someone say that as clearly as
this owner just did like i don't care if
they're murdered by the government of
china how do you feel when you see that
i remember we had a game today at 12 30
and my manager texted me this video
right before the game and first of all i
couldn't believe it i was very angry
very disgusted and very disappointed and
you know his comments were so
i i was like i couldn't focus on the
game because because of his comments i
mean you look at the uyghur people
what's happening to igor's is one of the
worst human right abuses in the world
today and there is a genocide happening
while we are talking right now and him
going out there and saying careless is a
shame and it is disgusting
i mean so you just became an american
citizen to see
the the most privileged the richest
people in our society some of them
anyway just say out loud like i don't
care about anybody but myself making
money having power over this country i
mean that must be kind of discouraging
as someone who just got here you know
you know the funny thing is this guy uh
this guy owns a company called actually
i have it right here called social
capital where they pretend to care about
social values and this is a virtue
signal and i have all these recordings
here with me he pretends to care about
others but the only thing he cares about
is money and
promoting the ccp propaganda and it
makes me sick how he's using social
justice to make money for risk of
company and i want to ask him one
question you know one question
if your mother if your daughter if your
sister was in those concentration camps
and getting tortured and gained rape
every day would you still think about
money would you would you still remain
silent so i want them to answer that
question
yeah i mean greed is a sin people used
to say that out loud no one ever says
that out loud now but you obviously
understand it um and i'm so i'm so glad
you said that and i'm so glad you're in
this country
thank you very much mr freedom good to
see you